welcome back if you struggle with
missing or unhealthy teeth comprehensive
dental care the sponsors of this next
segment have a lifelong solution for you
comprehensive dental care has been
changing smiles and lives in the valley
for 30 years my practice predominantly
is with dental implants plus i have two
dental associates who
take care of all the needs of our
general dentistry patients it's
estimated that over 175 million
americans have at least one missing
tooth so comprehensive dental care is
here to educate that population on their
best options my practice is focused
mainly on dental implants and
single tooth
restorations and full arch
replacement of teeth
i've been doing dental implants for 25
years
i am a
diplomat of the american board of oral
implantology i recognize
dental implant specialist in other words
dr hendrickson knows what he's doing
he's also one of the national full arch
restoration trainers for hybrids dental
lab which helps his practice stay
focused on comfort aesthetics and
function we have patients who have
had lifelong problems with their dental
with their dental care they've had
replacement teeth they've had
periodontal disease
and
they finally have reached the point
where
they've stopped living
okay we like to we like to talk about
giving
patients back their ability to enjoy
life the hybrid dental implant restores
comfort and confidence no matter who you
are the typical candidate can be anybody
we treat patients anywhere from 30 up to
90 years old has been my range
the typical patient that does walk in
they're either in a denture
they're having chronic pain and problems
with their teeth
they've been um
going to their dentist for the past
20 plus years having single tooth
replaced one after another every year
and they're finally throwing up their
hands and they're like i'm done i want a
lifelong solution and that's exactly
what comprehensive dental care provides
for its patients with hybridge they can
go on living their life implants
properly done
properly placed are the most
predictable longest lasting thing we do
in dentistry today according to dr
hendrickson the hybrid process is also
relatively pain free
patients typically say the first 18
hours are the worst
with just some soreness the next day we
can bring you in
and do the surgery
we typically bring in an
anesthesiologist to make sure you're
comfortable
and
the surgery is typically done in the
morning
and we bring you back in the next day
and we do a digital scan
which is the
it's the only system out there that's
patented for a completely digital
workflow
and three weeks later we can screw the
your teeth into your mouth and they're
done
so
you are only in temporary teeth for a
three week period of time but again
you're never without your smile
thank you to comprehensive dental care
for sponsoring this segment you can find
them in henderson for more call 702
735-3284
or visit nvdenta.com las vegas now we'll
be right back